ﾊﾟﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｰﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟﾝ♪
ﾝ゛ｯﾝ゛ｯ!
久しぶりにTwitter読もっと
www
AHAHAHAHA
AHAHAHA
［はじめの笑い声］
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
ペヤング焼きそば！
皆さん好きですか？
僕もう大好きですペヤング
お肉禁止してるんですけど
かやくを抜いて、わざわざ食べてます
ﾍｯ!!
この前ネットの記事で見たんですけども
このペヤングと
一時期ネットでも話題になってた
このストロングゼロ
ストロングゼロがね凄いね
何か...
ｺﾞﾎ
ドラッグ的な酔い方をするみたいな噂が出てまして
アルコール9%って強いんですけど
飲みやすいんですよね
こうなんか...ジュースみたいな感じで
知らないうちにべろんべろんに酔っちゃうみたいで
海外だとこんな何か、簡単に酔えるのが無いみたいで
外国の人からすると
何か外国から日本に来た人は
ストロングゼロ買いまくって
うわこれやべぇクレイジーだ！
ヤバいこれ決まるぜ決まるぜ！つって
どんどん決めてくらしいです...
お酒を進める為に動画を撮ってる訳じゃ
無いんですけど
ちなみに僕はこれ一本飲むと
ベロンベロンになります
後輩二人と僕で
飲んだときに
もうめちゃくちゃになっちゃって
(ああーAHAHAHAHA)
は：見て見て見て
後輩：え？
wwwwwwwwwwww
美味しいのに凄い酔えるから
やっぱり流石というか美味しいです
まず普通にペヤング作って来ます
かやくは
ちっちゃなお肉すらも僕は許せないんで
可能な限りキャベツだけピックアップして
焼きそばを作っていきます
OK！
もうざっくりと本当こんな感じです
お湯！
GO！
このまま普通に三分待ちます
どのタイミングでストロングゼロを入れるかと言いますと
普通に完成させてから...
それからネットで見たやつだと
あの普通の大きさのペヤングに
小さい缶のストロングゼロ入れてるんで
僕はデカイのとデカイのですからね！
最強レベルだ
ﾊｯﾊｧｯ///
一応リンク...記事載せとくんですけど
めっちゃみんな美味しそうに食べてるんすよなんか
マジ普通に美味しそうなんだよな
イイナイイナ
三分経ちました
お湯ポイ！
ｼｬｧ!
これまでに無いくらい丁寧に切りました
ああー...
うまそー
今、深夜の３時です☆
だから今日ね
この動画の為に何も食わないようにしてきたんで
めっちゃ腹減ってます
そして明日、朝９時からです
助けてください
まあそれも覚悟で僕はやりますからね
まずは普通にソースをかけて
ペヤングを作ります
ﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯﾌﾌﾙﾌｯ
シンプルに食いてぇなぁ！
シンプルにこのまま食いたいが
企画なのでちゃんと、かけていきます
ちょちょちょちょちょちょちょっとだけ食わせて
いただきます
うまぁ...
いや本当ね
お肉が無くても、美味しい
いや待って本当ちょっ...と...
えぇーでも
美味しいのと美味しいのを足せば
美味しくなるっていう方程式は
あると思うので
多分大丈夫だと思います
じゃあ、みんな
今日も１日お疲れ様。
乾杯☆
あぁー
あぁー↑
ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛
ｳ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛ｱ゛
いや待って本当に大丈夫なの？これ
ねぇシュワシュワ言ってるんですけど！
ねぇ待って待って待って待って待って
ちょ、ちょっと食べて美味しかったらもっとかけます
にぇーーーーーん
水気がヤバい
見た目はそんなに変わんないすね
ああ、もう吸っちゃう吸っちゃう
いただきます
どんな味なんだろ、全く想像がつかない
［むせたはじめ］
ぶぅおｺﾞﾎｯｺﾞﾎｯ
あれ？
美味いぞぉ！
美味い...
待って！美味い！
なにこれ？
あの...最初の刺激が強い
何か...レモン焼きそば見たいになります
そりゃそっか
ごめん、もうちょい食べさせて
何か変な...変な味だなぁ
勢いよく啜ると絶対何かｺﾞﾎｯｺﾞﾎｯなっちゃうんですけど
待ってこれ
何かね、ちゃんと焼きそばの味が残ってます
だってこれ甘くないからさ
甘くないレモン何で
焼きそばの美味しさを持ちつつそのレモン風味を
何だろこう...
唐揚げにかけるような
レモン汁をこう足してるみたいな、感じです
美味しいですでも
初動が凄い
うめぇなぁ
麺がぁ、焼きそばとは違う
あの...4545してきてて
凄い...
良いね（意味深
みずみずしくてOCね！
もうヤバい、もう頭ぐるんぐるんしてきた
すげぇ
僕！
焼きそば%#$@&?!AHAHAHA
すげぇ焼きそば食って俺酔ってるよ
めちゃくちゃ美味しいし食べやすいんですけど...
酔いますねこれ
ごちそうさまでした
いや本当凄い
あの、ペヤングも美味しい
ストロングゼロも美味しい
そして
酔っちゃう
全てが揃った（？）
まるで、悪魔のような
焼きそばでした！
はい！